[Music]
thank you
I think threads is going to pose a huge
threat to Twitter because it's coming
from The Meta and Instagram family of
apps Instagram has 2 billion users
compared to around 250 million of
Twitter so it's about 10 times bigger
already so if only one in 10 Instagram
users tries using threads it's overtaken
Twitter in the blink of an eye big news
today we are launching threats in open
and friendly public space
[Music]
thank you
until November last year Twitter did
have an active user base it wasn't
growing stratospherically but since Elon
Musk took over the system itself isn't
working as well as it should
[Music]